All right, everybody, we're back.
Janine Turner is coming
up in just a minute.
It'll be great to have
her on the program and-
Excuse me, Conan? Andy?
Oh, hey!
Folks, it's Todd.
He's one of our security
guards here at the program.
I'm sorry to bother you during the show,
but there's this woman out
here who doesn't have a ticket
and she keeps insisting
on coming in anyway.
Well, you can't interrupt
the show, I mean,
you'll just have to tell her
to come back another time.
Well, I would tell her to come back, Andy,
but she keeps claiming
she's your little sister.
(audience laughs)
Hey, Andy!
(Andy groans)
Oh, hi, yeah.
No, that is Andy's little sister, Stacy.
Hey there, Stacy.
Hi Stacy.
Hi Conan!
Yeah, we didn't know
you were coming today,
but it's really nice to see you again.
It is?
Stacy, remember how we
decided maybe it was better
if you didn't come to the show
for a while? Remember that?
Yeah, I know, Andy. I'm sorry.
But last time I was here
I totally spazzed out
like a super dork.
Well, it's okay, Stacy.
Yeah, you were upset because
you have a crush on Conan
and you found out he
doesn't feel the same way.
Andy, why don't you go, like,
tell Russia or something?
Look, Andy didn't mean to embarrass you.
I just don't wanna see
you get hurt, that's all.
[Audience] Aw!
You don't?
Stacy, last time you were
here you got pretty upset.
Look, since then I have
grown so much emotionally.
Stacy, that was four weeks
ago. That was a month.
I know that, but with the help
of both transcendental meditation
and my Judy Blume books,
I have come to terms with
my feelings for Conan,
and I now know that I need to concentrate
on boys my own age.
So I brought some
pictures to show you guys.
This is my room when I used
to be obsessed with Conan.
(audience laughs)
And here's my room now.
Check it out!
Yeah!
(audience applauds)
There's a sign in there
that says I Luv Hanson.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we saw.
I love the middle one.
Yeah.
Yeah, but Stacy,
your room is still
basically a shrine to Conan.
Okay, I appreciate your concern, Andy,
but I want you to know
that I am totally glad
that Conan already has a girlfriend.
You are?
Sure.
Without her there'd be
nobody to compare me to,
and then you would never realize that I am
your true, ultimate soulmate.
(audience laughs)
What?
Don't fight it, Conan.
We all need to experience
rejection of a relationship
in order to make room for
the arrival of true love.
Now, wait, Tracy, I don't
think you, you, you...
Or Stacy, I'm sorry. (chuckles)
(audience laughs)
Look, I...
(audience applauds)
Look, I don't think you understand.
I really am flattered, but
I like you as a friend,
and only as a friend.
What?
Come on, don't you think
we could be friends?
Oh, yeah.
Sure.
Let's be friends.
Tell you what, why don't I just sit down
and watch my friend do his little show,
all right?
Have a seat, all right?
I'm sure this gentleman won't mind moving.
Sir?
(audience laughs)
(laughs) No, I'm sorry. I
waited all day for this seat.
Get outta here, musclehead!
Before I break you in
half like a Twix bar!
Move it!
[Conan] Stacy!
(audience applauds)
Come on!
You know it!
Bring it!
Stacy, take it easy!
Take it easy, Stacy.
You shut your hole, Richter!
I got a sock full of batteries
with your name on it!
Come on!
Oh my...
Oh my god!
Come on!
I'll tell ya, I am outta here, everybody!
But I promise you I'll be back!
And when I do the walls will
tremble in the wake of my fury!
And you, O'Brien, you will
hang, drawn and quartered,
on the frayed ropes of my vengeance!
Are you there, God? It's me, Stacy!
(audience applauds)
Yeah!
Whoo!
Stacy!
[Stacy] Whoo!
Stacy! Stacy, stop doing that, okay?
I don't even know what that
is. Now, I'm sorry I upset you.
Don't you understand? I really like you.
I'm sorry too.
I mean, for some, puberty
is a sign of awakening,
but for me puberty is a raging
sea of psychosexual turmoil.
Well, wait a minute.
Well, then why don't you just sit down
and we'll get you some popcorn and then-
I can't eat popcorn 'cause
it gets stuck in my braces!
All right! Okay, just take it easy!
We're gonna take a little
break, we'll think of something.
We'll be right back with-